[Music]
i'ma what yeah now you're quiet you're
quiet right this is what we're talking
about this what we talked about right
what am i how about tell me tell me what
I am tell me tell me what I am a lot of
people thought this year was a throwaway
year but perhaps this is the year that
gives us 20/20 vision
there's a huge movement underway
currently we all know this we all know
why it started breaking news in the
killing of George Floyd his cries I can
breathe sparking protests across the
country over the last nine days at a
time when police misconduct is in the
spotlight
there's a social contract that we all
have that if you steal or if I steal the
person who is the authority comes in and
they fix the situation
but the person who fixes the situation
is cutely not yesterday we sat down to
try and figure out what we're going to
say and how we're going to say it what
actions did we want to take both as
people and as a company in all my time
in quarter and I've had an incredible
time here we've never discussed race and
our experience with it in America now I
was hesitant to have this conversation
for many reasons
it's an incredible way to carry I wear
this skin every day the pain of my
ancestors is literally embedded in my
DNA so I don't want to misrepresent my
community worse than the wrong message
some might say by having this discussion
you bring the monster back to life and
feed into the divide that we sometimes
pretend doesn't actually exist but the
opposite is true by having this
discussion we're able to address the
fact that there is a bubble and now it's
time to pop that bubble but okay you
might ask how does any of this help how
do I help should I even help right now
there's many mixed signals donations
marching staying silent being vocal
posting on Instagram rioting everyone is
taking a different approach and many
people still don't know what to do to
support the movement nor do they
understand it enough to make a
difference so I want to give you the
most recent example of lingering
systemic oppression that is still
present today literally yesterday I'm
writing my one-wheel I'm coming up on
the right hand of someone and I say
excuse me
on your right I passed by the man he was
a little startled but then I heard him
screaming so I take off my headphones I
look back and he's yelling you stupid
don't ever pass me literally right there
is what we're talking about this is what
we talk about right
what am i how about tell me tell me what
I am tell me tell me what I am exactly
this is the problem people this right
here this man feels superior enough to
talk down on me as if I am nothing as
he's yelling at me I'm looking at him
and I just I feel bad for him I'm pretty
sure this is something that was tots and
regardless of where he's at today it
just proves that this hatred is
so ingrained in his heart it's still
bubbles so back to the conversation we
sat down and tried to figure out what
actionable steps we could take and this
conversation lasted for five hours and
it wasn't until the end of that that we
realized we had actually just done the
most valuable thing we could do
we had popped the bubble we had
addressed the elephant in the room
prior to the horrific killings of
Brianna Taylor Ahmad Aubrey and George
Floyd I would never have had this type
of discussion with the guys I would have
been in my own bubble with my black
friends discussing our pain like the
fact that I would just discuss with my
friends then come in and just as
business as normal is a problem within
itself you know we have to be able to be
open and acknowledge that there is a
problem that's that's the that's the
beauty in in this new revolution that
we're living in that were discussing
things that we'd never that we pretty
much ignore is the elephant in the room
we are fully addressing they were
standing right in front of it and being
like yo this isn't right it's a great
feeling but you know it doesn't just it
is a stop after that it's like we we are
making a change for the future you know
for your kids you know for your kids for
everyone's kids honestly like in that
right there is just amazing like this
moment right here
me and you chillin and talking about
something we never II I've never had a
discussion like this never through
conversations bad ideas get exposed to
sunlight and they wither away so here at
corridor we would like to encourage you
to go out and have a hard conversation
and if your views cannot withstand being
challenged then perhaps those views
aren't worth having in the first place
I've been dying for this ice cream all
day oh you can't go wrong with cookies
and cream and a cone on top it's like
ice cream oh yeah okay okay so this
video is part of an ongoing conversation
to help educate the world on steps that
we can take to help end systemic racism
and the vilification of black people let
us know in the comments below the
conversations you plan on happening or
if you've already had these ongoing
conversations because if we keep the
conversation going this doesn't just
become a fad that fades it becomes part
of our culture in the description you'll
find a compilation of organizations that
you can donate to if you choose to add
to this
please DM my friend Royce he'll be more
than happy to add any type of
information that can help this movement
continue going thank you so much for
watching this video and let's change the
world together